according to our current understanding
of the universe the physical universe is
actually made up of energy and
information wherever there are objects
there are fields of energy and also of
information and if you go to the very
fundamental levels of activity in nature
you find that nature is a discontinuity
which means even though perceptual
experience of the universe is that it's
continuous in fact it's going on and off
at the speed of light we know what's in
the honor of the universe its energy and
information we use it in our technology
when we use cell phones or selfie
information however on the internet a
cell or send each other email but the
deeper question is what in the off
what's between the two ons in the
discontinuity and many people in quantum
physics in the world of quantum physics
are realizing or thinking or
hypothesizing that the discontinuities
consciousness itself that consciousness
is not a byproduct of evolution as has
been suggested or for that matter an
expression of our brains although it
expresses itself through our brains that
consciousness is the common ground of
existence that ultimately differentiates
into space time energy information and
matter and the same consciousness is
responsible for our thoughts for our
emotions and feelings for our behaviors
for our personal relationships for
social interactions for the environments
that we find ourselves in and for our
biology in other words consciousness is
the ground of being the differentiates
into everything that we call reality
including the observer and the objects
of our observation and this is a much
deep
understanding of consciousness that is
coming about as a result of some
insights from the world of quantum
physics not everyone agrees on this
theory in fact a number of scientists
are still tied to the old paradigm which
is that matter is the essential reality
and that consciousness is the epi
phenomenon but it turns out that even to
explain simple things how do you
perceive color how do you imagine how do
you see pictures in consciousness near
sounds and consciousness you have to
recognize that this can not be explained
by any reductionist model when you
experience a sound or a color or a taste
or smell the activity in your brain is
just a code of charges that goes on and
off how does that code of charges going
on and off become physical reality and
where does that happen if we understand
this model of quantum physics then it
becomes apparent that we're not in the
physical world the physical world is in
us we create the physical world in the
when we perceive it when we observe it
and also we create its experience in our
imagination and when I say we I don't
mean the physical body or the brain but
that deeper domain of consciousness
which conceives governs constructs and
actually becomes everything that we call
physical reality this is a model that is
being explored by some cutting-edge
scientists both in the field of
neuroscience and also in the field of
quantum physics but it is also a model
that was explored by the great sages and
seers some of whom were the authors of
the bhagavad-gita